[Musique]
benoît tout ça va vous allez bien ouais
la forme c'est important en ce moment
alors la base ce soir on devait être 150
et merci d'être là on met 20 donc à la
base à ma place ça devait être gad
elmaleh mais l'organisation du tedx et
10 quitte à réduire drastiquement
l'événement autant prendre un mec qui
nous coûtent rien donc enchanté moi
c'est oscar alors le thème de ce soir
c'était export new paf fait bien accents
les plus bilingues auront déjà compris
explorer de nouveaux chemins de nouveaux
horizons et on entend par là innovation
c'est vrai c'est très à la mode c'est
l'innovation tout doit être nouveau
aujourd'hui nouveau concept nouveau
portable nouveaux saints la dernière
fois que j'ai entendu ce mot innovation
c'est quand j'ai demandé à ma copine
comment faire chaque jour pour pouvoir
continuer de la séduire je me rappelle
el mahdi ben je sais pas innove elle m'a
dit fais quelque chose que tu n'as
jamais fait auquel tu pense depuis
longtemps et qui te procurer du plaisir
un peu dans ta vie je lui ai dit écoute
je suis pas pour la fidélité à la base
donc et dans l'innovation entend start
up 1 ça aussi c'est très à la mode la
start up j'ai pas trop en parler ce soir
parce que à titre perso je préfère le
travail mais non je charrie les start up
mais il ya beaucoup d'avantagés à
beaucens start-up verte a marqué ceux
qui ont bossé aime bien le rappeler il
aime bien dire tout ça au score à
l'avantagé des océans start-up fait que
tu peux faire en fait plusieurs
activités que tu pourrais pas faire par
exemple se lancer dans une
multinationale
ils ont raison c'est vrai après il faut
pouvoir le faire est-ce qu'on a tous les
capacités de gérer un dossier important
est de remporter le tournoi de baby foot
organisé par liliane la happiness
manager ça je sais pas tu vois ouais
c'est un métier
happiness manager la meuf et manager du
bonheur c'est à dire que tu as quand
même des philosophes des lumières qui se
sont cassé le cul pendant presque un
siècle pour pouvoir trouver une
définition au bonheur et en a pas un qui
a trouvé rythme à liliane 1
l'autre elle t'a fait un bac + 5 mois
aliev de t3 s2 saint germain en laye tu
vois le truc et elle va t'apprendre
comment aller au taf avec le smile toi
happiness manager c'est cela
l'innovation on a eu beaucoup de
superbes interventions ce soir
pierre-marie jour est menée au pari de
l'urbanisme nous a fait passer comme
message qu'il fallait absolument occuper
tous les espaces qui nous sont alloués
il arrivait tout à l'heure on lui a dit
par contre tu es gentil tu restes sur le
tapis rouge du sort pas du cadre
pierre-marie c'est un mec qui a des
convictions mais qui est flexible quand
même toit le truc et donc il nous a
parlé des rez-de-chaussée
particulièrement nous a dit voilà
aujourd'hui les rez-de-chaussée était
trop occupé qu'il fallait absolument
remettre de la vie dans ces espaces
on est tous d'accord quand même pour
dire que pierre marie n'est jamais allé
à barbes 1
car là bas tous les rez-de-chaussée sans
utiliser à l'urbanisme et à son
paroxysme et c'est pas toujours une
bonne chose à bon terme de rez de
chaussée à barbès tas de possibilités
t'assois un salon de massage vietnamien
avec finitions manuelles et crois moi
que quand à 6 heures du matin je pars
pour aller au taf et que tu as les
semelles qui colle au carrelage à cause
des semences de la veille tu aimais un
petit peu de réticence à l'urbanisme sur
le coup tu vois des liens ou alors deux
un kebab tu sais celui avec écrit sur la
devanture ici kebab fait maison et quand
tu vois la gueule de la maison tu
réfléchis à deux fois quand même avant
d'y rentrer tu vois mais souvent
d'ailleurs tu y vas pas ce que tu aimes
le danger quelque part
et puis toujours à propos de nourriture
nous a présenté un nouveau concept
excellent my food quelques risques sans
déconner my food jouard fait c'est un
écosystème qui est basée à domicile donc
chez nous qui nous permet de nous auto
suffire en termes d'alimentation et
c'est dingue ça quelle révolution
moi je sais que le problème de ce genre
de chose si je l'avais chez moi c'est
sam empêcherait enfin je n'y ai même
plus faire mes courses au supermarché et
je sais qu'il ya des choses qui
manquerait que si plus pouvoir par
exemple admirer le sourire radieux des
caissières tu vois c'est vrai
pouvoir tout trouver dans les rayons on
tente ils sont rangés de manière
cohérente et structurée
mon histoire vraie je faisais mes
courses et là pendant confinement pour
noël et je tourne comme ça dans le rayon
de sueur du caviar
je suis chez lidl le caviar était
positionné entre du jambon herta et un
cordon bleu père dodu moi je vous dis
qu'elle est l'idée du chef de rayon en
termes de merchandising je dis c'est pas
possible les mecs qu'ils ont peut-être
une prime à celui qui ferait au mieux du
grand n'importe quoi
je me dis si aujourd'hui on tend
consommateur ça ne choque personne et
c'est possible de trouver ça dans les
rayons bientôt ce serait possible que tu
ailles par exemple à la halle aux
chaussures tai chi bonjour monsieur je
vous prendre une paire de louboutin s'il
vous plaît ouais super mettez moi ça de
côté avec ça je vous prendre le savez la
fameuse marque avec le petit crocodile
non pas la coste crocs très bien mais
témoin une paire de crocs et une paire
de louboutin
super merci beaucoup et et ça ne choque
personne je crée personnes aujourd'hui
c'est ça ce qui manquerait aussi de ne
plus pouvoir faire mes courses au
supermarché ça ne plus pouvoir se je
crois qu'on fait tous juger les gens à
travers ce qu'ils ont pris dans leur
caddie tu sais quand ça commence à faire
dix minutes que tu attends dans là que
parce que l'autre elle a laissé son
gosse de trois ans pourrait chercher
trois rouleaux de pq a toujours pas
trouvé le rayon toi tu es la ceinture et
atteint monde fait tu regardes être fait
qu'ici la prime senna qui bowles est ce
qu'il ya là dedans sorbate de potassium
sympa gomme duhart possibilité de traces
de kérosène quoi ah oui quand même
ok d'accord encore un qui passera pas 40
ans puis au gouvernement la tente
comment ça se fait un petit peu un petit
peu longue donc un petit peu énervé à
temps et puis tu essayes en fait de joe
de regarder pour pouvoir jauger à quelle
distance était de la caisse mais
n'arrive pas parce qu'en face de toi une
dame un petit peu enrobé tu fais plus
tard il y avait le père dodu voilà la
mer d'eau du thé mais chiant à ce moment
là c'est vrai et on a beau dire ce qu'on
veut mais si tu regarde comme ça si tu
prends un petit peu de recul sur nous
êtres humains quand on fait la queue à
la caisse
qu'est-ce qu'on est con on est quand
même très très loin de l'intelligence
collective nous a parlé christophe tout
à l'heure
christophe il nous a dit à travers son
exemple principalement des skins game
entre autres que s'il ya plusieurs on
arrivait à allier nos compétences on
pouvait aller chercher plus loin que ce
qu'on aurait pu faire seule c'est bien
dire après je me perds mais il faut
aussi voir quelque chose c'est que
souvent qui se ressemble s'assemble
cités débrouillardes ça va
c'était comme moi 0 x 0 c'était toujours
0 on va pas faire dans la mare cheval de
course la guerre et moi connaissant mes
compétences en termes d'évasion bon
c'est pas une demi journée que je passe
à me faire bouffer le cul par ira dans
le jeu moi ces quarante jours pour moi
c'est plus dû tourner skyrim c'est koh
lanta avait truck n est pas si vous
connaissez d'ailleurs koh lanta vous
connaissez un peu
ouais ça c'est l'intelligence collective
ça c'est intelligent que plusieurs
dizaines peut-être centaines de
personnes qui se met sur un même projet
pour un fait sortir une émission qui va
battre des records d'audience alors
collective peut-être intelligence tu
prend en compte que tu en moyenne 11% de
la population mondiale qui crèvent la
dalle est à 24 mai qui ont trouvé une
bonne idée de tenter l'expérience pour
la déconne pas exagérer quand même et
c'est possible ensuite en rentrant c'en
est un qui dit dans une interview dont
le retour était une chose que j'ai perdu
qu'est ce qu'ils au pardon j'ai tu
t'attendais à quoi voit le côté positif
des revenus tour a déjà j'ai beaucoup
aimé e c'est également le talk de
véronique vraiment super intéressant
pour rappel véronique elle est senior
vice president general manager business
unit économique a marqué c'est tout
voilà pour ceux qui se posaient la
question je vais demander de thaler est
la bienvenue son brevet des collèges
il n'y a pas de souci là tu vraiment
tout est tiré de ce côté là et donc elle
nous apparaît de l'économie circulaire
l'économie circulaire qui le fait de
remettre à neuf des pièces automobiles
pour les ajouter sur les véhicules
actuels pour grossir un petit peu le
très vulgairement
c'est un peu ce que pourrait faire un
chirurgien esthétique sur nabila à la
différence qu'aujourd'hui la voiture est
intelligente elle
faut quand même pas si c'est vrai c'est
une question qu'on pourrait se poser est
ce qu'une personne refaite de la tête
aux pieds prenons les frères bogdanoff
par exemple est ce qu'une personne
refaite de la tête aux pieds métiers de
la jugeote
c'est de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est vrai la beauté je me dit quand tu
regardes le nombre de cons qu'on est sur
cette planète
mais c'est vrai il ya des comptes
partout que c'est comme si on était dans
la salle d'ailleurs je sais pas et
quelque part on est tous le compte
quelqu'un aujourd'hui un petit peu votre
bouffon qu'on soit dit entre nous mais
quand tu regardes le nom de con qu'il ya
sur cette planète et qu'aujourd'hui même
les voitures sont intelligents c'est
dire à quel point la technologie a
dépassé les 3 1 messieurs dames bonjour
là il ya pas longtemps
j'ai commander l'iphone xls ouais je me
la pète je les commande est gelée reçu
le sort normalement sortir je vais
commander gelé reçu j'ai décidé normal
qu'on compare nos visions de la vie j'ai
regardé la vie telle que moi je la vois
puis j'ai ouvert sa caméra il vaut mieux
la vie que moi ce bâtard c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une société
où c'est possible qu'ils afflelou viens
de te voir sur ton canapé ils te disent
écoute une paire achetée 14 offertes et
c'est ton iphone qui a dit sur 10 aux
deux yeux tu vois le truc c'est ça la
société aujourd'hui c'est sa
l'innovation et le pire c'est que moi
j'avais côtoyé ses petits cousins tu
vois j'ai côtoyé iphone 3 iphone 4
iphone 6 il avait qu'un seul objectif
derrière là j'ai acheté le xs il a deux
objectifs derrière je sais pas si vous
avez vu la pub pour le 12 le truc qu'il
a trois objectifs derrière
aujourd'hui l'iphone n'a plus d'objectif
que tu en as dans ta propre vie
ça ne choque personne alors je sais pas
si vous avez vu là ça y est c'est la
grande nouveauté c'est le grand truc
hein c'est excellent soi-disant les
iphone ils vont sous l'eau ils vont
souvent il ya 5 10 ans est ce que tu
aurais pensé ton iphone aurait été
capable de te battre en apnée mon iphone
il peut aller jusqu'à 2 5 mètres de
profondeur moi je vais à peine à deux
mètres j'ai plus d'oxygène j'ai plus de
souffle avec votre crevé mais un simple
j'ai mal aux tympans plus de sens pour
dire et notre iphone les chercheurs ont
fait en sorte que notre iphone puis s'il
restait des heures d'aussi belles
innovations c'est intelligent très c'est
un poisson veut se taper un gandhi crush
tu vas prendre un petit cellfish ne sais
pas
et quelque part je charrie le fait que
voilà aujourd'hui les technologies
presque nous surpassent mais je pense
que si on en est là aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on leur donne du grain à moudre
vous la voyez la transition tout fait
avec une très belle intervention qu on a
eu ce qu'on est toujours sur les réseaux
sociaux on est toujours sur nos
portables et concerne donc du coup ces
réseaux sociaux on nous a dit tout à
l'heure que toute notre activité étaient
enregistrés sur des algorithmes donc à
notre insu et qu'ensuite on était
manipulé de a à z en nous proposant des
publicités qui avait forcément en
rapport avec vos centres d'intérêts mais
c'est fou quand même on est manipulée de
a à z
alors je tiens quand même à saluer tous
les mecs de ce soir qui sont fait
démasquer
je pense bien évidemment à ceux qui
avant un spectacle disaient à leurs
copines cheville je ne comprends pas
pourquoi j'ai que des pubs du cul sur
instagram je veux dire
ah non mais ces deux sociétés ne vit que
par le sexe est désolant plus y en a ça
fait plaisir ce soir il y en a qui ont
pas envie que le spectacle se termine du
coup et je me dis que quelque part si
tout ça c'est rentrer dans des
algorithmes et qui plus est des matches
qui plus est une science exacte
il ya vraiment des publicitaires qui
sont mauvais quand même il y en a ils
sont vraiment mauvais hockey
revenons en 2018 coupe du monde de
football au cap antoine griezmann et
égérie de braun le mec le plus un bear
de l'équipe de france ne fait la pub
pour un rasoir ça n'a choqué personne
aujourd'hui je me dis en termes de
marketing on avale tout ce qu on doit
analyser quoi c'est vrai je vous dis
quelle est la prochaine étape
obispo égérie de franck provost polanski
pour les couches pampers c'est pas vous
ne verrez davantage c'est qu'elle ait eu
l'oeil pour aller enfiler les couches 1
j'ai trouvé que les interventions de ce
soir ont vraiment tout était très
intéressante et je pense qu'on a besoin
de messages positifs comme ça de
nouvelles idées de nouveaux chemins pour
pouvoir les converger aller chercher
plus loin ensemble le problème dans la
société actuelle c'est que j'ai
l'impression que ces idées plutôt que de
converger elle s'oppose jeudi il suffit
de voir dans le monde actuel société
actuelle caisse qui gère le monde
l'argent on a le sexe et cyril hanouna
mais bon ça c'est un autre débat
ici on prend juste les deux premiers le
sexe d'un côté c'est que je ne prends
pas l'acte sexuel même si bien
évidemment il en fait partie je prends
côté masculin féminin et que je le lis
avec l'argent il ya des machistes ce
soir dans la salle alors moi je tiens à
le dire avant toute chose je suis
féministe hockey non pas que je pense
que vous ayez besoin mesdames d'une
présence masculine pour vous aider dans
votre cause
vous vous débrouillez déjà très bien
tout seul à la non non ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est un sujet important
qu'il faut prendre à bras le corps moi
je vois la fois j'en discute avec ma
copine
qu'est ce que tu penses du fait plutôt
est ce que tu trouves ça normal que les
femmes gagnent en moyenne 2 7 % de moins
que les hommes puis 2,7 pour cent mais
c'est énorme
je ne sais pas normal pour moi je gagne
1300 euros par mois je peux le dire
parce que c'est pas beaucoup ça fait
plaisir
je gagne 1300 euros 2 7% ça fait 35
euros deux mois pour une femme par mois
c'est énorme pour un couple ça fait deux
mc do en moins par mois rendez compte
c'est toutes les femmes me regarder et
elles se disent il est mignon il est
avec nous dans notre cause et les mecs
regarde les leurs femmes et 10 après
tout deux matelots en moins ça peut que
lui rendre service oublie ça on a encore
du travail à faire je crois sur le
féminisme et j'aime bien cet exemple
parce que je trouve qu'il illustre
vachement bien
le fait que le fond tout ça dans cette
société si on est dans merde rac et
d'aujourd'hui pardonnez moi c'est que on
a du mal à accepter nos différences
c'est vrai dire et on fait les naïfs tu
vois on aime bien dire du contraire ce
tueur la vérité c'est que ça tire sur
les contraire la personne barça ne le
dites et je pense qu'on a vraiment
besoin de tout le positif comme on a eu
ce soir pour pouvoir pour faut pouvoir
juste se rassembler quelque part et d'un
côté je trouve que si aujourd'hui on
regarde la plupart des innovations des
nouvelles start-up chaque jour qui
sortent et les idées je trouve cela
alarmant que la plupart des nouveaux
chemins concerne l'intelligence qu'elle
soit artificiers le collective je vous
dis que si l'on veut tant innover sur
l'intelligence collective c'est que la
connerie individuelle est déjà trop
présente
je me dis que si l'on veut de temps
innover sur l'intelligence artificielle
c'est qu'on en a déjà mais rld est
quelque part sur le naturel alors
prenons exemple sur toutes les belles
idées qui ont été dits par nos
intervenants ce soir pour pouvoir un
autre échelle faire un petit pas vers
l'innovation
celle qui se sert des difficultés
passées pour pouvoir en tirer des
perspectives positives pour demain à
titre personnel maintenant si je
reprends le thème de ce soir explore new
paf et que je me rappelle de ce que m'a
fait comme définition de l'innovation ma
copine celle qu'elle a décrite à travers
quelque chose de nouveau auquel je pense
depuis longtemps
ils pourraient me procurer du plaisir
pas devant vous ce soir je crois que
j'ai innové
alors merci mots
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]